hot breath i mean you know for stand up
it was
like i just looked at the game i was
like okay what do i need to do first of
all i need to get undeniably funny
that's the first thing how do i get
unnaturally funny get on stage as much
as i can
so i was barking for a club which means
handing out tickets
to go to a club in exchange for stage
time so i was getting up tons of times a
week in front of real audiences
very early on in my in my career i was
probably getting up
five seven times a week in front of real
audiences early in my career
unheard of so i had to say new york this
is in new york
yeah then i stopped working at one of
those clubs i kind of got like fired
from barking or one club closed they
didn't ask me to work at the other one
so i
i basically we found this other place
that was around the block
and they had shows there and um they
were just kind of like free shows asking
people to come off the street and i got
involved in that club and i started
working for one of the guys there and i
we were just kind of friendly and i was
running his shows i just found a place
to get up
consistently and i started running a
couple shows there with friends we were
just asked pete strangers from the
streets to come in
and um it was great because when you
have your own show you have your own
show
a lot of times it might be repeat
audience
so you can't work the same jokes out
because it's the same audience
so it's good because you're practicing
new jokes but you're not getting good at
anything
you know it's like you're learning a new
um like pool shot every week
it's like you're not getting really
better pool you're just kind of getting
marginally better
at these new jokes that you never really
get to try but we could work on the same
jokes for months
because it was a different group of
people coming in every
week so we did that
then i once i felt like i was undeniably
funny
at least funny to the point where i feel
like i could you know be on stage with
these other guys who are on stage
and how long in your career was that a
few years in i mean
i mean now i would look back and be like
oh i was awful but for the time
i was able to go you know i'm i
i'm good enough to be on the stage with
these guys
and uh i was like why are they on the
stage so i started analyzing the people
i saw at all the clubs
and it was like charade small like james
smith and these kind of
comics and um
they were all in best week ever i
noticed all the comics who are
best week ever were performing at all
the clubs christian finnegan
and i was like okay i need to get on a
show that is a weekly show
that will give me some leverage so now
because it's not just about funny it's
like
if you're as funny as all the other guys
okay you got to be funnier than them
and have something so i got on a guy
code
and that was my weekly now i had some
leverage now i could go to a club and be
like i'm on a tv show every week
can i get on yeah how do you how did you
get on guy code
i uh make it sound so easy uh yeah it
was it was
it was kind of there was some you know
one of the good things like knowing what
you want to do
so like i i did a new year's eve show
like
one of those countdown shows for mtv so
i got into the mtv door
they really liked me so i
had a meeting with them i was pitching a
show
which i ended up not really wanting to
do but at least like the person saw
i was interesting uh and then
while pitching it uh she asked me like
what my thing was and i was just like i
just you know i got a guy's perspective
like i'm unapologetically male
and you know this is how i feel and i'd
like to be the voice for
you know for uh for men nowadays and i
feel like they don't really have a voice
and all of a sudden guy code came down
the pipeline and she remembered that
meeting she's like i'd like to suggest a
guy
now had i never said what i truly want
to do
maybe i would have never got that
meeting right most people
i think put this white umbrella this
wide net but the net is so wide it never
catches anything
and i'm saying if you say specifically
what you want to do to people when a
project comes up to specific
they'll think about you for it if you're
like i just want to be on television
nobody's remembering the meeting where
the guy goes i just want to be on
television
and going okay i should put that they
will remember the meeting they said
listen i love monster trucks that's my
[__] i'm a monster truck
aficionado if a monster truck show comes
on
they can be like i remember meeting this
guy who's into monster trucks you know
what i'm saying so know what you want
and then when something comes down the
line
people tag you for it there was one time
you were on
five shows yeah simultaneously yeah
i was a guy at mtv for a minute so you
understand the tv game and all that
maybe you could provide some insight
into
maybe first off even just how to pitch a
show what are they yeah i mean i didn't
pitch any of them
you know yeah i was just i just had a
contract with mtv and they could put me
on as many things as they wanted
and um there was a moment in in history
and mtv where i was the guy you know i
hosted everything from
a dating show to his jobs show i was
on guy code girl code jobs that don't
suck i hosted spring break i hosted
another
you know festival like i was just they
would just throw me on every
award yeah i hosted the emas out there
in europe for like the american
syndication of it
but it was uh it was a cool time man i
was just busy as [__] and
bouncing around they put me on
everything it was it was definitely cool
yeah we're not on the same page anymore
is that you just grew apart or an event
happened uh
i think an event sparked it but also
they it was also
some frustration on both of our parts um
you know i i i hmm i also think maybe
like uh
i don't want to blame my manager but i
think my manager made some poor
decisions at the time i'm no longer with
him but i think that
led to a kind of aggravated relationship
between the two of us
like he allowed me to do a show on a
competing channel that i thought was
okay to do
but it turns out it wasn't that kind of
pissed off the mtv
folks but after we already had a little
bit of a
you know kind of tumultuous relationship
i didn't want to do any more corny shows
gotcha i had bad experiences with a
couple corny shows and i realized i'm
not really into that i want to do these
kind of fun
interesting shows and um
they also wanted to make a show kind of
based on brilliant idiots
and i felt that that was our
entity in our project and they kind of
felt like since they introduced me and
charlemagne that they
owned it not owned it but like we're
entitled to it creatively in some way
i was like nah fam that's not what it is
so that show ends up
being on common sense